Terminator Doug fate has screened for
critics and while the franchise has left
them in the cold in recent years
it looks like the trend is about to be
reversed I'm back a good deal of the
reviewers who took in the film are
comparing it favorably to Terminator 2
Judgment Day and many also agreed that
the film will make a star out of
Mackenzie Davis Linda Hamilton's return
to the role of Sarah Connor was welcomed
and the flicks intriguing story and
slam-bang action sequences were also
singled out for praise having said that
we're cautiously optimistic that the
initial reactions the Terminator Doug
fate will hold up because the flick come
to the pretty dance telling pedigree it
functions at the direct sequel to t2
ignoring all of the increasing
ridiculous sequels that followed that
film talk to the hand
it also marks James Cameron's return to
the franchise as a producer and it was
helmed by Tim Miller the man who brought
us a piece of pure cinematic joy that
was 2016 s Deadpool Gabrielle Luna has
been well known among Marvel circles
since his inspired performance as Ghost
Rider in Marvel's agents of shield and
fans are no doubt excited that he plays
a souped-up terminator in this movie so
what do the critics have to say about it
for starters the folks at Collider were
rally blown away by the flick
editor-in-chief Stephen Weintraub was
among the many praising the performance
of Davis who stars as a cyborg sent back
in time to protect a new mother of the
future portrayed by natalya Reyes
Weintraub enjoyed the trifecta offered
by Davis Reyes and Hamilton he wrote
Terminator Doug Feith is easily the best
Terminator movie since t2 has some
fantastic action and loved how the film
features three female protagonists that
all kick ass so awesome seeing Linda
Hamilton back as Sarah Connor in a
follow-up tweet Weintraub at a word of
recommendation for those unfamiliar with
Davis work writing I've been a fan of
Mackenzie Davis and seeing her in halt
and catch fire but she takes it to
another level in dark fate where she
kicks all kinds of us if you like her
work in dark fate go back and watch
holton catch fire
Collider editor Perry in a mirror off
seem to touch surprised to be penning
such a positive response saying it's
Terminator dark fate the best since t2
yup Linda Hamilton's return makes a big
difference Mackenzie Davis kicks all the
ass and Natalia Reyes as an
excellent Anka Gabriele Lunas rf9 is a
winner to physicality BFX fights all
spot-on but they gave this another go
their colleague horror editor Hayley
foutch offered a similar opinion it's
solid super well articulated action
Linda Hamilton is aces easily the best C
course since T to dark fate takes the
force awakens if it ain't broke don't
fix it mentality the Camerons films and
turns out two ain't broke MS felch was
not the only observer to notice an
aesthetic similarity between dark fate
and the movie that watched the bad taste
of the Star Wars prequels out of the
mouths of fans his modo entertainment
reporter Jermaine Lucia wrote the movie
is basically terminator the force
awakens a satisfying exciting reboot
that's essentially the best parts of t1
and t2 in a blender davis Reyes and
Hamilton are excellent the action Wow
and while is familiar it's easily the
best t3 yet Terminator is back slash
film owner editor Peter skater also true
the comparison although he did make sure
to point out that Miller is well know
Cameron
Doug fate is better than you think it's
going to be it's trying hard to be the
force awakens' of Terminator movies and
mostly succeeds but it's lacking
Cameron's innovation evolution and
directing Arnold is fantastic the best
of his post t2 Terminator appearances
Scotto wasn't the only to sing praises
of ani who has certainly caught his
share of flak for continuing to show up
in the Terminator franchise well into
his golden years of course there was
also plenty of praise to go around for
Hamilton who apparently had no trouble
stepping back into the skin of a most
famous character a prog senior
entertainment writer Mike Ryan said I
was skeptical of dark fate thought the
trailers were not great but I would up
enjoying it quite a bit and the
difference-maker versus the other post t
two sequels is Linda Hamilton it's
always been her story and Hamilton adds
her needed weightier screen crush
editor-in-chief Matt singer agreed
wholeheartedly
terminator is thought of as Arnold's
franchise Doug Feith makes it clear he
wasn't the key ingredient that made it
work it was Linda Hamilton she's
incredible in this and the movies very
solid all in all it was a pretty amazing
outpouring of love for a sequel that
nobody was sure would work and it seems
to accomplish the impossible in making
some
critics actually look forward to more
Terminator movies these initial
reactions certainly seem to confirm that
Terminator dark fate may finally at long
last be a terminator movie that doesn't
come out of the gate having to justify
its existence
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
[Music]